[Música]
y nuevamente hablamos de economía en
directo américa de france24 está en el
estudio daniel hablando nada ni hablemos
de occidente porque aprobaron más
sanciones contra rusia claro como
respuesta a su invasión sobre ucrania
los países de la unión europea añadieron
a su lista de sancionados a 14 oligarcas
políticos rusos y sus familiares también
van a desconectar a tres bancos
bielorruso del sistema swift que es el
sistema internacional de comunicación
por el que pasa la mayoría de
transacciones bancarias del mundo y
congelan adicionalmente las relaciones
con su banco central por considerarlo un
socio de rusia en esta guerra el bloque
de los 27 agregó que sus líderes van a
discutir sanciones adicionales este
jueves incluyendo más bancos y más
personas los únicos de raúl que no se
han atrevido a tocar son las entidades
rusas encargadas de las transacciones de
por la venta de petróleo y sus derivados
de entonces cuáles son las más recientes
medidas de ucrania y rusia para proteger
sus respectivas economías pues
comencemos por el lado ucraniano el
gobierno o prohibió las exportaciones de
productos como cebada trigo azúcar sal y
carne hasta finales de este año según
una resolución del gabinete publicada
este miércoles por su parte rusia que es
un gran exportador de minerales y de
hidrocarburos anunció que priorizará el
suministro de granos como el trigo a las
panaderías nacionales sobre las
exportaciones y es que recordemos raúl
que entre ucrania y rusia proveen una
tercera parte del trigo mundial por otro
lado el banco central ruso limitó hasta
septiembre a 10.000 dólares el máximo
que un cliente puede sacar en moneda
extranjera en efectivo desde sus cuentas
internacionales el resto de fondos que
tengan lo pueden retirar pero en rublos
ya sabemos que su valor ha caído en 50%
frente al dólar desde que inició la
guerra además difícil de encontrar en
este momento pero ya hay respuesta por
el veto estadounidense a los energéticos
rusos años pues este miércoles el
kremlin acusó a joe biden de declarar
una guerra económica y advirtió que está
analizando cuidadosamente cómo a
responder analistas ya dicen que rusia
podría quedarse con cientos de miles de
barriles de represa 2 todos los días
mientras se reacomoda el mercado
petrolero mundial y las grandes cadenas
de alimentos se dieron a la presión y se
van de rusia claro cada vez son menos
las empresas occidentales que quedan en
este país como consecuencia de la
indignación por la invasión a ucrania
algunas de ellas también fueron blanco
de críticas en las redes sociales ahora
estas empresas que son el emblema del
capitalismo occidental pues se den a la
presión pública y anuncian su salida se
sumó más recientemente en este lee que
es el grande el más grande productor o
mejor vendedor de alimentos del mundo
horas antes el gigante de hamburguesas
mcdonald's anunció que encerrar a sus
850 restaurantes
pepsico va a detener las ventas de
bebidas pero no de productos esenciales
starbucks clausurar a sus 130 locales
cocacola también hará lo propio al igual
que kfc un montón de compañías ya se
están yendo del país como lo explica una
analiza los efectos que tiene
creo que el gesto simbólico más grande
aquí es que cuando mcdonald se mudó a la
unión soviética fue parte de un mensaje
de apertura y construcción de confianza
y cooperación entre rusia y occidente y
ahora todas esas vías han sido cerradas
así que estamos de pie al menos
simbólicamente ante una nueva era de
división entre rusia y gran parte del
resto del mundo
rosell dice que de simbólicamente pero
no es tan simbólico porque mire este
éxodo de inversiones también tiene otros
efectos las principales agencias
calificadoras rebajaron la nota de rusia
en varios escalones y prevé en un impago
inminente de sus obligaciones de deuda
tenemos que estar pendientes raúl el 16
de marzo debe pagar 107 millones de
dólares en intereses de unos dan y
entonces con todo esto cómo están los
indicadores los mercados pues mire que
los esfuerzos diplomáticos para tratar
de acabar con esta guerra han tenido un
buen efecto en las bolsas europeas que
recuperan muy buena parte de sus
pérdidas de días anteriores suben hasta
el 3 por ciento 5 por ciento en el caso
de alemania las bolsas asiáticas si
cayera con fuerza después de conocer la
inflación china que se aceleró con
fuerza en febrero el precio del petróleo
está perdiendo un poco de terreno frente
a días anteriores de los máximos que
venía de varios años y sentirse cotiza
en torno a los 120 dólares por barril
había llegado a 130 142 millones bueno
danny gracias entonces por toda la
información económica nos vemos la
mañana con más probamos directo